- Say I have a lot of
mental anguish myself.
- [Mark] Oh, you do?
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] What do you think caused that?
- Family, mainly.
- [Mark] Tell me about your family.
- [Damian] Mother, heroin
addict, a prostitute;
father, a Hell's Angels,
biker, heroin addict
just all kinds of crazy stuff.
Like they told me I
was born dead, I guess,
with the umbilical cord
wrapped around my neck
from an accident my mother got into.
She didn't have me in Oklahoma
where she got in an accident at.
She flew back to California to have me.
And that's why I was born dead.
And then so they did an
emergency C-section, whatever,
saved my life.
But then at six months
old, I guess, they told me
that I had colic and that
I was ruining their high.
So they drove down the road,
we lived right on Lake Elsinore,
they drove down the road,
threw me in the Lake at six months old.
And my father and mother
were telling me this story
like they were talking
about the weather, you know,
like no big thing.
And they're like, yeah,
you were ruining our high
so we threw you in the lake, you know,
and went back home,
fixed, you know, got high.
We're kicking it about
ready to fix it again,
like four hours later, when we
hear this knocking scratching
on the door, dad kept opening
the door, didn't see anybody.
So he's getting pissed, you know,
like the fifth, sixth time,
he said I was gonna just murder somebody.
I thought someone was
ding-dong ditching, you know,
and come to find out the
sixth time he opens it,
and right before he closes, he looks down,
and he sees me soaking wet,
smiling, but I'm not coughing.
So they let me in.
And that's how they finished the story.
They're like, you basically
weren't a buzzkill anymore.
So we let you in.
I was like, alright, thank you.
- [Mark] How was you childhood?
- Horrible.
Grew up watching mother
suck and fuck for money,
you know, for dope.
Like being in the same bed
and everything, you know?
Yeah. So that was pretty horrible.
And then watching her just do all kinds,
I actually watched her
five to six years old
beat some man to death in a
hardware store out in Riverside.
The dude cut us off
and we were in a pickup
truck with no lap belts
'cause it was an older truck
and she slammed on her brakes.
I flew into the dash, busted
my nose, that pissed her off,
so she ran a couple of red
lights chasing the dude down.
Chased him, he pulled
into a hardware store,
She jumps out after him.
She's like, wait here in the truck,
I'm like, oh hell no.
You know, I was a little kid.
I wanted to see what was going on
and followed her in and just
watched her beat this man
to death with tools off of the shelves.
Yeah. Like giant wrenches,
you know, a hammer, I think,
was a hammer or something big,
like a pickax or something
was the final tool that
she used to kill the guy.
He stopped moving, stopped crying.
So she gets up off of him, spits on him.
And she sees me and she just grabs me,
and she's like, I told you
to wait in the fucking truck,
come on, let's go, grab me--
- [Mark] How old were you?
- Like five or six.
- [Mark] Did she get caught?
- No.
And then she did get caught though,
trying to break my stepdad out of jail.
Like he was in Riverside County,
and they planned on an escape, whatever
but he blabber mouthed to his celly
and his celly ratted him off.
So me mom and a sister and little brother,
brother was a baby at the time,
we'd go walking into
Riverside County courthouse
and just get bummed rushed
by like 20 million sheriffs
or whatever, you know,
the DOs that protect the
place, the bailiffs, I guess.
And they tackled her.
She had two 45s on her and
she was gonna thoroughly,
like escaped him from jail, you know?
And then that's when we
got sent to a foster homes
and a foster home thing was
like a real hectic ordeal
because they they're always
like splitting us apart,
you know?
And then finally I got
placed into a foster home.
Thomas Lee West Jr.
His uncle is Jerry West,
the owner of the Lakers.
He molested me for five
to six years of my life,
beat me thoroughly, too .
Like one time I caught the
house a little bit on fire
'cause he told me to start the barbecue.
And I was like 10 years old, you know,
I didn't know how to start no barbecue.
I got gasoline, you know,
that's what I thought.
And the charcoals, you know,
poured gas on the charcoals,
lit it up and the flames started dripping
out of the bottom, you know,
cause I poured too much gas on,
and it caught the hose on fire
which put a black mark on the
side of the house, you know,
'cause it burnt their house a little bit.
And so he beat me with the
barbecue, like beat me with it.
You know, guy was like, he was something,
he was my teacher too,
teacher slash foster parent.
And then so after going through that
for like five to six years of
my life, I finally ran away
because he said he was
going to do the same thing
to my little brother that he was doing
to me because I was telling him, no.
I didn't want to do it anymore.
I, you know, I was finally
like getting old enough
to stand up for myself and you know,
not be so scared and everything.
He was 6" 4", you know,
200-something pounds.
And I was like tiny
little, nothing, you know.
- [Mark] And what was he having you do?
- Suck his dick, basically.
I mean, and then like,
I don't know, I have sex,
he would like imitate sex, but like
shave his legs or whatever, you know,
and tell me to, you know,
basically have intercourse with his legs
you know what I'm saying?
And then he would suck
my dick, too, you know.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- 10 to 15.
So after I ran away and
told the cops, you know
they still didn't take
away his teacher's license
or his foster parent
license because he still,
unfortunately ruined six other
children's lives after mine.
And so when I was like 23 or
24 or something like that,
Riverside finally called me
and said, asked me to testify.
You know, I came out and
you know, I was pumped,
you know like, all right, you know,
I'm not this little
kid, no more, you know,
feeling, you know, antsy, you know
like I wanted to, I wanted to hurt him,
basically do what he did to me, you know?
But then when it got
down to it, I was there
and I was just going off
on him, just yelling at him
calling him all kinds of names.
And I even spit in his face, you know,
right there in the court and
the bailiffs didn't do nothing.
They were like, we were hoping
that you were going to beat his ass.
We weren't going to touch you.
We were just going to
let you do it, you know.
And I didn't because I was afraid
that I'd go to jail for it, you know.
And I mean, a part of
me said, I don't care.
But then a part of me that's
like the good part I consider said
you're just going to
be like him, you know.
Like what good is it gonna really do you
to assault this man he's sitting
here and he was crying too
you know, as I was going
off on him, you know?
So I mean that, like, I guess
it made me feel empowered
in a way, you know, that
I wasn't a weak little kid
and that I got this big
man crying, you know
and like scared basically, you know.
- [Mark] Did he get a conviction?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How many years?
- I think it was like 42
years or something to life.
I don't know if he's still alive or not.
My stepfather and family and stuff,
said that they're going to put word in
to have him taken care of, you know.
So I don't know if he's
still alive or not.
- [Mark] So where did
your life go after that?
- [Damian] Went to grandmother's.
Sister was there for like a year or two
before me and my little brother.
Straight A student.
I was actually nation's top
5% of high school students.
And I had a scholarship to anywhere,
Harvard, Yale, anywhere.
But I didn't find that information out
until I was 26 because my
mother, she kept all the letters
from me and that like,
she set it up one day,
she's like, yeah, get me some cigarettes
from my bed table because I
was letting her live with me.
I had a house and everything
was taken care of her.
'Cause she had a lung cancer.
COPD, basically the life
of a drug addict, you know,
was really hard on her.
So she needed taking care of, you know.
So I was taking care of
her and stuff, you know,
paying the bills, everything,
doing everything right.
And she's like, yeah,
give me some cigarettes.
And I went and grabbed her cigarettes.
And I see this letter sitting right
on top of her pack of
cigarettes with my name on it.
And another letter underneath it
one was open and the other
one was still closed.
I look at it and I read it.
I'm like, what the fuck, you know?
How come you didn't tell
me I had a scholarship?
She goes, I didn't want you
to shine brighter than me.
I'm like me shine brighter than you?
I'm like ma, you're a black hole.
You know, there's no shining
coming from you whatsoever.
So I mean, for me to
shine brighter than you
I don't really have to do
all too much, you know.
But basically I was 17,
just to have this prosthetic knee put in
for a motorcycle accident,
still had the stitches and everything.
And my family left me homeless
while I was still in high school
because mother put all the
blame for all this stuff,
she stole all on me and grandmother.
Like we would show, me
my sister and brother,
we would show grandmother dope
and everything that mom had,
you know, trying to get
mom some help, you know,
but grandma wouldn't have it.
You know, your mother's no
drug addict, blah, blah, blah.
We take her into the bathroom,
a needle sitting in my mom's arm
you know, blood everywhere,
dope everywhere,
and our grandma would say,
why are you guys trying to set
up your mother for me to get mad at her?
And we're like, we don't
want you mad at her.
We want you to put her into
rehab so she can get better.
You know, that's all we wanted.
But she just couldn't have
it because I mean, for her,
I guess to admit that
her daughter was a junkie
would I guess reflect on her, you know?
So she wasn't having none of that.
So they left me homeless, still crutches,
holding boxes of my stuff
still in high school.
And I basically had to drop out
and start selling drugs
so I could survive.
- [Mark] Now you're living on Skid Row?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How long have you been down here?
- Four years.
- [Mark] What's your drug?
- Heroin.
Now it's fentanyl.
Haven't touched heroin since October 14.
I went into rehab and everything,
detoxed and everything, you know,
and got out and I was like doing good,
but then like stress,
stressors come at me, you know.
And that pretty much brings
me back into the game.
- [Mark] Is your family still around?
- No, mother passed away.
Father passed away.
Grandmother's still around.
Brother and sister and grandmother
are in Arizona right now.
But that's where I left
though to come out here.
'Cause I had to get away
from my ex out there.
'Cause she's a total psychopath.
She slept with a cop
that she had arrest me
for criminal damage.
And the criminal damage
was her breaking my dishes
over my head.
You know, but because she
was sleeping with him,
hence the criminal damage, you know.
And then they said it was
a domestic dispute, too.
So they made me go to anger management,
domestic classes, you know
domestic violence classes,
whatever, and stuff like that.
You know, and I did all that.
I mean, pass all that with
flying colors, you know
and did the probation
thing for three years,
passed that too.
And then found out though
that she was cheating
on me with a bunch of people, you know.
- [Mark] And you have now kids?
- Two, but I'm not sure if they're mine.
Like I raised them for the
first 10 years of their life,
you know, but,
finding out that she's sleeping
with all of her ex boyfriends, you know,
people she went to school with,
people she works with, you know,
all kinds of people
because they were sending,
she even had a secret phone
that I didn't know about.
They were sending her text
messages on stuff like,
oh so when's that a piece of shit
gonna go to work so I can come by
and see you and the kids,
this was on my birthday.
And then another text
was show me your boobs.
I'm like, what kind of
immature, childish shit is this?
I showed it to her.
She didn't want to even look at it though.
You know, she's like,
leave me alone, I'm busy.
' Cause she was on Facebook.
Hence I call Facebook Fuckbook.
- [Mark] So what are
you doing for money now?
- I panhandle.
Or recycle.
Trying to keep it as
legitimate as possible.
I mean, I would love to get a job
but you can't really acquire
a job without an address.
I mean, they tell you, you can
if you lie and put down somebody
else's address, but for me
like that's just appalling, you know.
How are you going to hire
somebody and tell them initially,
before they even start working, to lie?
You know, that doesn't seem like the kind
of relationship that you
would want to have transpire
for somebody that's going to
be working with you, you know.
Their initial appearance starts off
with a lie about where they live.
And so I just told him, like
I just told him, honest,
I was like, I don't know anybody out here.
I don't know any addresses
that I could use, you know.
And so I got hired and fired
like right then and there.
- [Mark] Do you have any plans?
Anything you'd like to
see happen down the road?
- Yeah. Get back into school,
definitely get off drugs
and hopefully do something
to better society.
You know, like I have all kinds of ideas.
You know, like when I
was in seventh grade,
I came up with a science fair
project, how to clean pools
chemical free with a UV light.
You pass water underneath it
and it destabilizes the
molecules' original makeup
of H2O and reforms it into H2O2,
hydrogen peroxide.
As long as it's in a
enclosed containment system
with no outer light, you know, available.
And then when you put
it back into the pool
after cycling the peroxide
in with regular water,
it kills 99.9% of all germs
and bacteria and stuff.
Or you put it back into the
pool during the day in the sun
having all the UV rays,
transforms the molecules
back to their original state of H2O.
So it's water cleaning water, pretty much.
I won the science fair with it.
Figured I could get
probably millions, just,
you know, not putting it
out there, but I'm sure
that by now it's 'cause it's
seventh grade, long time ago.
Somebody already thought of the idea
or utilize my idea to do
something with it, you know.
- [Mark] Well Damian, thank you so much
for telling me your story.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you for coming in.
- I appreciate you very
much and what you're doing.
Thank you very much.
God bless.
- [Mark] You're interesting.
- Thank you.